I'm bisexual I'm not only attracted to
women I'm also attracted to men and
people that fall under other gender
spectrums Christine and Cody Brown's
daughter Gwendolyn opens up about her
sexuality on Sister Wives I think I
probably have some influence on their
dating life possibly maybe more so in
the past now I try not to meddle
um at all the 20 year old sexual
orientation came up as a topic as she
and Christine were helping Isabel pack
up for college can I just say
gwendolyn's humor is 90 of the time
inappropriate and uncomfortable Isabelle
stressed out enough that I don't know
what this is going to do not very nice
oh no that's very nice
it's about what it's pride month you
can't talk to me like that I'm bisexual
and for Christine that didn't come as a
surprise when Mariah told us that she
was gay a immediately I thought oh
so I was Gwendolyn I knew immediately
Mariah is Mary's Child who now goes by
Leon they came out as transgender in
June and their Journey played out on the
TLC Series in 2017. that she knows
herself and understands herself and is
willing to accept who she is is
something to be celebrated but we've
tried to do with our own family is just
allow that space for each child to grow
up and really Embrace what it is that
they want to embrace and for Christine
she's all about embracing Gwendolyn for
who she is we've had just great
conversations about it she teases me
about having celebrity crushes on women
and that I'm also partially gay I'm not
but she loves she loves teasing about it
but hey Christine does list her own
celeb crushes Blake Lively Kelly
Clarkson Emily Blunt they're just
beautiful
I can't help but admire them
but it would only go that far I'm
definitely heterosexual not interested
in you know not that close
as Isabelle prepares to move away Cody's
adjusting to Janelle's choice to live in
an RV I do not want to live in the
trailer I wish Chanel would have been
able to find a house and for Cody with
Christine leaving him on top of Janelle
making big Life Choices it's led him to
some healing with Mary their
relationship has been Rocky for years
right now I'm in the call of bitterness
with Christine on the other hand I have
a fondness for Mary because Mary and I
are getting along
I don't know what is healed but I'm not
feeling betrayed by Mary
I feel betrayed by Christine I feel like
my relationship with Mary is very good
but it's not a married
situation it's an amiable relationship
but I don't think it's a fulfilling
relationship for Mary not in any way
it's a estranged marriage it's it's a
marriage that needs to work out some
stuff
foreign
[Music]